okay uh
welcome back to the afternoon session
we're gonna have a short session this
afternoon uh just two talks
uh and then uh
longer break before the
uh reception so our first talk uh
joining us from uh luzon is raphael uh
bertierro who will be talking about
nonparametric convergence rates okay
well thank you
so thank you uh hi everyone and thank
you for this opportunity to present my
work
so yes i'm currently a postdoc at epfl
but today i will present work i've done
before during my phd
at inria in paris and so it's joint work
with my phd supervisors
francis back and pierre gaya
and so today i'm going to present
one bond essentially for lgd so one
converges rate of stochastic grain
descent
and compared to what you might know
the the challenge will be to
to prove something for what i call plain
vanilla
sgd
meaning that we will try to avoid some
of the tricks that people use in order
to to prove bonds on hdd
so we will not regularize the objective
and we will not take decaying exercises
and we wonder uh if we do not do this
what can we prove
uh but okay let me define a little bit
of a setting
so it will be a supervised learning you
want to predict an output y from boot u
when you have access to samples
from the joint law of u and y
you seek a function that minimizes the
quadratic risk which is the average
square error between f of u and y
today i will speak only about
about linear regression meaning that i
assume that the predictors that i that i
seek
are linear in some potentially nonlinear
transformation
of the inputs so i will call phi the
future map and i will seek function f
theta of the form and theta dot
phi of u
and so now because i'm going to do only
uh i'm going to look only at linear maps
i'm going to parameterize the risk r
as a function of
theta just to make things simpler
so it sounds very naive but as you know
it also incorporates
kernel regression so
rkhs theory essentially tells you that
kernel regression
kernel regressions are implicitly a
linear regression
in some potentially unknown
feature map but what you have to
remember is that is that in this case
very often the feature space will be
infinite dimensional
so what i'm trying to do today is an
analysis of lgd
[Music]
on for linear regression but in infinite
dimensional spaces
so
so of course the choice of the future
phi or the choice of the kernel it
indicates a very strong prior on the
structure of your problem and actually
it will define a regularity class
regularity classes on your health space
age
and so how do you define those those
irregularities you take the covariance
operator
of your features so it's an operator
sigma and goes from an infinite
dimensional space to an in-dimensional
space and you define the the image of
the powers of sigma
so the larger the power the smaller the
image and this defines a nested sequence
of subspaces of h
and these are spaces of regularity so
the larger the exponent
the more regular are the elements in the
image
and so you can use that to measure
whether something will be easy to learn
or not so for instance assume that you
are in the so-called
attainable case meaning that your risk
is minimized at a linear predictor fita
star
in that case you will measure the
regularity of this optimum by looking at
the
highest alpha the largest alpha such
that theta star is in the image of sigma
to the power of power 2. this gives you
a number alpha 1 a real number and this
measures the regularity of the optima
similarly you can measure the regularity
of the features
as alpha 2
being the largest alpha such that
features for a few are in the image of
sigma for the true or motion
and sometimes people call that under
many majors but maybe like a source
condition for the first one and capacity
to condition for the second
and so these notions are often used in
non-parametric analysis so in
infinite dimensional spaces in order to
measure
the performance of different estimators
and so a classical work is a work by
caponeto and
they analyze the performance of ridge
regression
and they show that if the regularization
parameter is chosen properly depending
on these two parameters and the number
of samples
then the excess risk satisfies a certain
bound
and they show that actually this rate
is is optimal for this class of problem
so today i want to present something
different because i don't want to
analyze rich reflection i want to
analyze a stochastic grain descent
because it's heavily used in practice
and to reduce computational costs
and some people have already done this
so
so many people have
have analyzed hdd in a non-parametric
setting and the deco message is that you
can also reach the same optimal rates
if you use a certain number of tricks
including decreasing step sizes
averaging and regularizing
however
many people like in practice it seems
that people are not using these tricks
so much
and
in simulation seems as theory
overestimates the importance of these
tricks
maybe we do some of these assumptions
because it just makes the proofs easier
and so we try and best work to do
something completely different we want
to take plain vanilla igd and see
whether it works well or not
what do i mean
by plain vanilla igd well you take your
risk you take the grain of the rest it's
an expectation
and then this gives you stochastic
grains and we will do single past hdd on
the data we
you we will not regularize and we take a
fixed step size
and we wonder how well
can this work
and so uh we
we still use the same notion of
regularity
and we get the following
theorem
so we also control the
expected excess risk
but now first because we don't take
decaying step sizes we expect at some
point
sgd to take a random walk around the
optimum
and so
this is the term on the right and this
the excess risk in this regime will be
proportional to the step size that you
have chosen
and proportional to the risk of the
optimal predictor
and before that you will have a
polynomial decay
and the rate will be the minimum of the
two regularities plus one
so one of the two regularities will be a
bottleneck for the first convergence
of the algorithm
so what can you use this for so this is
a third example of how you can use this
bond and i'm going to take a non-linear
case a kernel regression to emphasize
the thing the fact that we do not do
only
linear regression
so in this example we want to predict to
we want to estimate a function here in
blue a function f star
and we observe it
perfectly at random points
sampled
in the unit interval
and wonder can we estimate this function
from
the observation at random points
and we can take in order to perform this
estimation
something that you might want to call
kernel
and it works as follows
for instance you start from the naive
estimate the function is constant equal
to zero so this is the left figure and
the middle figure you see one update
you take a little kernel so it's a it's
a bum function you center it around the
point that you have absurd and you just
add a bump in order
and for your your estimate to match
the observation at the point that you
have a c
and then you see new points coming in
and then you just update your function
using the kernel and you wonder okay
how fast can this converge to uh to the
true function f star
so here is the result in that case
and here we it will depend on the
classical notion of regular variety
which is servo left regularity
so if you assume that f star is in hr so
the super space of regularity r and the
kernel is in h s
you get a certain rate of convergence of
f k to f star
which is okay a polynomial and you get
the exponent and the exponent depends on
r s
and so here on the dimension so i i put
plots in dimension one but you can
imagine uh estimation on the unique cube
in general
and then for instance you can choose you
can use these bonds to
find what is the best kernel for hdd for
kernel lgd so here the optimal
smoothness of the kernel happens to be
the one that maximizes the exponent here
and it happens to be s equal to r
same regularity as the function
and i don't know if this was obvious
from the start
um but uh okay take home message and we
give rates for lgd depending on
non-parametric
quantities and this rate make a pure
trade-off in the choice of the
programmer a trade-off between the
regularity of the optimum and the
regularity
of the features
in the case where there is
low additive noise so maybe you want to
call that the interpolation setting
and then
so the risk of the optimal predictor is
close to zero then plain vanilla hdd
will converge and you can even achieve
fast rates if the problem is record
let me end by thanking my collaborators
francis and pierre and thank you for
your attention
any questions
actually
um
i'm can you go back to the uh
uh
two slides i think with the
optimism so
if you understand correctly here the
smoothness the behavior in this moon is
is there something to balance the choice
of smoothness or if i choose it
to be even smoother it seems
uh
sorry i i guess just using less smooth i
mean when you say that optimal is s is s
equals r things become
worse if uh
on either side of it because i'm
[Music]
um so so
so yes so in this problem you don't
choose r because it's uh
you choose s yes
and uh and so here you have a minimum
between two quantities in the exponent
and one is increasing in s and the other
is decreasing in s
and so there must be a
point where
where the maximum is achieved sorry i
missed the negative sign there i didn't
see that it was a balance it looked like
both monitor in the same direction
thanks okay
small question uh the the the big o and
small o here uh is uh
constant d and then to infinity that is
the setting
uh
[Music]
ah okay
big o small o okay so um
so here we are keeping the dimension d
constant fixed and then you're letting n
to infinity that's
yes yes so everything is for n to
infinity and uh yes small in the
exponent because i think uh
yes we just show something for if you
compare to
like if you had an exponent epsilon you
remove epsilon from the experiment
other questions
okay
thanks for getting us almost back on
track in terms of timing and that's uh
our next